well thank you all there thank you for
that introduction I want to thank
everybody for coming first of all I know
everybody's taking their free time and
also from faraway places
we've got Florida we've got Colorado New
York and any place in between so tonight
I'm just gonna break the night down into
five categories and just talk about the
life of a working screenwriter because I
think a lot of people think it's
glamorous which it's not and it's you
know hell of a lot of work just to get
anything made on any size screen on
television or features and the key which
you know why called this stain in the
game is you know everybody has this
concept of making it and I did too when
I was I went to UCLA film school and I
always thought you know making it was
you know we graduate and someone would
you know hand us a three-picture deal
you know out of college which obviously
was not the case it took me six years
after film school to land my first
professional job of which I was fired
six weeks later so and I was around
Christmastime so you can't write it
worse scenario than that and I thought
you know that was my I'd waited tables
for 10 years and done various odd jobs
just to get through college and I had oh
it only said that I was going to quit
that job you know the waiting tables if
I was going to get into the business so
I said goodbye to my you know my friends
and they said oh when you coming back
and I said never and of course six weeks
later I was fired but I didn't come back
but I didn't come back ever I did
catering but I had a script that was
optioned which was my first spec it was
my fifth spec that I've written and I've
written 36 feature screenplays and my
you know whole life of which 20 were
assignments and I've written nine TV
pilots which two were assignments and I
sold one spec like I said so it's been
it's been a long journey and like I said
making it I think is getting your next
job because you're always you're always
looking for your next job you know so
let me just show a show of hands how
many people have written a screenplay
okay how many have written one to five
screenplays oh wow okay
five to ten Wow five to ten ten to
twenty ten that's a president Chen
that's good that's uh that means you're
serious because I find a lot of times
you know someone just writes a script
and then they don't you know which I'll
talk about later about thinking about
the bigger picture of like why is his
script I also consult on the side and I
read a script and I say why would the
writer and I'm not bashing the script
but why how does this fit into what your
scope of the bigger picture because you
have to think that way cuz it's a
business you know you can't just think
about the one-off screenplay and then
not have anything else
and I always ask writers you know why
why are you doing this you know well is
it for fame fortune and glory because
there is none you know I was 11 years
old making films with my friend who got
a movie camera
so it's been my life's dream and I was
just you know like David Mamet says the
one who just wouldn't go away
you know and and in a way that's good
and another way you have to I mean
obviously if you're working ten years
and you don't see success you can
continue but some people may may not be
you know cut out for this you know I
mean and at some point I've had friends
who were actors and also writers who
said I you know I'm done you know I want
to have these other things in my life I
want to stop sacrificing and you know
and if you have a day job you know it's
keep the day job because if you're doing
okay that's alright but I never had a
day job you know I worked odd jobs you
know always and then I had a day job one
time in my life and it was at a law firm
but I had already been in the field so
it was hard to go back because it was a
slow period and I was like well what
nothing's nothing's cooking and so a
friend of mine was a was an attorney at
the firm and said we're looking for
people I said I don't want to get locked
into this so I did it for two years and
even at the time I'd had a movie made
while I was working the day job but it
wasn't enough money to quit so I
continued on there and then I gave my
notice the day that I got a phone call
from a production company and I'd worked
for them before and they said well why
haven't we heard from you and I said
well I I've been around
they said we have a fast track movie are
you available I said absolutely and hung
up the phone and I gave the two-week
notice and you know and it because I had
already been used to taking that leap
it wasn't like wow I'm giving up this
fantastic job making you know X number
of dollars a year to give up for this
chance it was like no and I remember
quitting and and the office manager said
well I guess we expected this to happen
someday cuz you know this is not what
you do and I said yeah I'm not a
paralegal it's okay you know
I have to go I have to go back to my
writing life so we talked about specs
you know you've got your specs there's a
lot of rewrite work out there people I
find some writers think it's some I
don't know beneath them maybe to rewrite
scripts but if you I've done it many
times if you can have the ability to
rewrite other projects you're gonna work
and many times you can share credit
which is important as well and so you
never know the job that you take example
being was a 2 years ago I took a rewrite
job and it was a ridiculous because a
lot of times you're going into a
situation that's not good you know I
mean it's it's a mess and they want you
to clean up the mess and you can be left
holding the bag and then whose fault is
it or you can do an amazing job and fix
it so I remember saying yes to the job
and it was a ridiculous like we want it
in two weeks it's all course hung up the
phone I was like what did I just do are
you are you crazy but it you know it
forced me to become a faster writer and
it's something I had to do if I was
gonna I was gonna play in the circle
with the people that had contacts with I
had to step up my game or say no now I
did the rewrite job I got Co credit and
it led to four more jobs with the same
company so my point in that is you never
know what job you take that you think is
going to be you know and I now want to
do it you have absolutely no idea what a
job will turn into you know I mean with
with the contacts and connections so
you've got rewrite work spec jobs and of
course
what I've been blessed with is
assignments I've sold one speck but that
opened the door for Simon twerk with the
company that made the speck and they
said hey with this is this is the kind
of movie you want to make and now we're
making other films and so I was like yes
and so assignment work
I've spoken to some writers and
obviously they don't understand that
most of the movies they're written our
assignment jobs you know mostly they
hire writer producer brings a writer in
and producer either pitches the idea or
they say we have this property and we
need a writer okay then it becomes your
idea because you have to go through
writing the treatment or the outline and
then writing the final screenplay
so assignment is the bread and butter of
working screenwriters so it's the place
to be is is doing assignment work you
you need your specs but I think you
should look at it more as calling cards
and learning experiences you know I mean
it takes three or four scripts to get
even in my opinion to know your style to
know the craft itself and to be you know
know your style how you want to open a
scene how you your voice you know when
someone reads a script they could say oh
I understand that that's your I see what
you you do differently than you are you
and that's what you want it you want to
find that brand so assignment work is is
important I mean it's the bread and
butter you always have to work write
your specs but you can't look at them as
million dollar sales I mean that's why I
used to look at when I came out of
college was like oh everything I wrote
would get made it's not the case and
then once I started getting paid I
thought everything I got paid for it
would get made which is also not the
case because right now I have five
projects that are as we say development
hell and their production ready scripts
that I was paid every draft for but yet
they sit on a shelf somewhere you know
for a myriad of reasons that are that
are not up to me international
marketplace changes company changes the
genre that they make financing falls out
but that's not my fault but a lot of
those screenplays I go back and reading
them like damn if I could only buy that
script back you know it's sitting there
on a shelf and maybe some
which I'll tell you a story someday just
happened I wrote a movie ten years ago
it was actually the film that got me out
of the law firm and it was sitting dead
and so they just Boop now there's a
heartbeat left on it I got a call I was
like are you kidding me
basically it's like found money because
I don't have to work on it anymore it's
already ready and done they may not
happen but it was just funny as an
example of like you can never know when
something is truly dead
and it's out now to an investment group
before with four other scripts so it
could happen but it's just my point that
you never know the journey of a project
even after you're paid to write it
doesn't mean it's gonna be Muni even
projects now this has not happened but
projects that were made you can also
have distribution problems where they
don't get shown or they don't go on you
know so there are a lot of things that
once you start working it's hard to
swallow that pill and go god you know
it's frustrating and it is but also I
try to craft the idea that it's a job
you know what I mean it's it's a career
in a vocation but it's a job like any
other job that you have responsibilities
and it just has to be a creative job and
like I say I'm very blessed to get up in
the morning and do what I love for a
living because many people you know get
up and hate their job and they work for
the weekend most weekends I'm actually
working but it's okay I love it you know
what I mean screenwriters sometimes
don't get weekends off and that's okay
when you love what you do because Monday
and Tuesday can be my weekend you know I
have the ability to shift my schedule as
long as the work gets done
so first scripts will probably not be
good which is fine they're learning
experiences they're tools like I said
and you don't show them to anyone
because I love on Twitter when someone
says I just finished my first script how
do I get an agent and I'm like you don't
not with your first script unless you
know it's the most amazing thing ever
and it you know no offense but it
probably is not and what's your backup
I'll talk about that we talk about
representation what's your backup
you can't you can't entice someone's
interest and have nothing else I had a
friend who made an independent feature
and it didn't sell took ungodly amount
of money in time and they're like great
ok that's nice but what he didn't have
anything else and I was like you don't
even have another screenplay you know so
this is why I talk about strategically
thinking about what is your key just
don't willy-nilly you know you could
write it as a hobby but you have to
consider you know the very methodical
plans which always you have to bob and
weave with it obviously but you can't
just have one the one script or the one
script that took you you know six years
to write because what what are you doing
for that other six years if you want to
work that's okay some people have I've
heard some people say well I you know I
just want to work on my spec and you
know that's all I want to do okay got a
good day job pay the bills fantastic
you're ok with that but if you want to
do it as a job as a working screenwriter
then you have to have product you have
to have an output of solid screenplays
to show you know that you're not just a
one-trick pony so talk about before you
consider writing your idea in the genre
I've written different genres because
I'm blessed because the different
companies say oh we want this kind of
movie and write it but generally the
first genre you sell is going to be the
movie that you're known for if you you
know sell a comedy they're not gonna
send you out to write action movies you
know they want to put you on lists to
say oh you use a comedy rewrite guy or
used to you know whatever so and you
should be writing things you you like
and forgot what the writer said but you
know don't write a Nihal if you don't
like romantic comedies or you know I
mean so if you're trying to force the
issue it's gonna show in the project
you're gonna know it's kind of like I
can tell the writer really doesn't want
to write this thing you know it doesn't
like the genre and and I think it's ok
to be pigeonholed actors complain about
it but if you're known for a particular
genre you're gonna work
you know and I've always been I'll first
to say I love to work I love to get up
in the morning and sit down and write
that script and you know if you're
scattered which I've had the experience
of coming to an age and they go what do
you got
she opened the trunk you go I got a
Western I got a thing I got a thank you
there whoa whoa whoa how can you write
all these movies well I don't get it how
am I supposed to sell you as a writer
how I what's your best project and so I
find people say well just give me your
best project I know they're all the best
project you know I was like yeah but you
know what I mean it's like so you come
up against that and yes everything I say
tonight the rules can be broken I'm just
telling you from my own experience in
the last 20 years so everybody in this
room is gonna have a different
experience and does and will have a
different way of breaking in but there
are certain things that just happen to
all of us you know and especially the
nature of the business when when you
know it's a business unfortunately and
if you can get some good stuff in there
that's great but you know I produced an
independent feature it took us three
years would I do that again
I don't think three years of my life is
worth that he's a great learning
experience but it's just too hard you
know it's too you know and then you
decide what do you want to do you want
to be a producer you want to be a writer
I always wanted to be a writer because I
was interested in creating the product
and writer can work anywhere in the
world you know this year and in the
spring I was in Italy so I was working
on a project doesn't matter where I am
at laptop the internet connection
producer doesn't care if I'm in LA as
long as the job gets done and I'm on
schedule out even durtschi you know so
now how many people when they write
their specs consider the budget all
right yeah
I never did when I first started I you
know we said write big you know whatever
100 million dollar budget which is I
guess the average now for Hollywood film
you know budgets gonna I consulted I'm
like looking at script I said Wow
unknown uncredited writer this thing
can't be made for less and I'm just
estimating a hundred million dollars
there five places in the town that can
make this movie and what are the odds
that out of the 50,000 registered a year
that this thing's going to get made so
you've locked yourself in now yeah you
can shrink the movie down but holiday
they're not gonna buy and go yeah we
think we you know we make five million
dollar budgets so what you need to do is
really it's too much development process
there they want to get a script that is
a five million dollar budget script not
a hundred million dollar budget script
and I'm not telling you tell anyone what
they need to write but it's even more
important now than it was in the past
then when people used to throw money at
scripts a million dollars to take it off
them you know they just don't do that
anymore
I think there's 75 specs you quote me
and we could be wrong we sold last year
you know at the studio level 75 that's
terrible and and those numbers were down
from the previous years you know and
another statistic and I always say not
to scare you and you probably already
know this it's approximately 20,000
writers in the guild and last year 5,800
reported income and these are WGA
writers all professional writers who
have had a credit you know five thousand
eight hundred and out of those 1940 were
feature writers so the restaurant TV so
the majority of writers and the guilded
television writers because a lot more
projects obviously and I remember back
in the day you know coming out of film
school that TV and features TV was kind
of looked down on like you know features
were it and so I would meet an agent and
they would say well I don't know anybody
in the TV world so what are you write
all right features you know want to sell
them for big money you know like the
people who graduated from my school did
you know but now it's cry there is no
it's seamless big people JJ Abrams you
know they're all working to get cross
back and forth and fast that people
who've started in TV go to features they
go
back so the point being you know
diversify your writing you know if your
specs are hitting walls try TV pilot you
know I wrote a web series which I never
thought I enjoy 9 episodes of a season
with a director and I never thought I
would enjoy it but I was like web series
you know I love the hell out of writing
that thing because of the constraints I
liked it and so now I say well I have a
web series that I've written a TV pilot
you know and I don't mean a show that's
been on write an original TV pilot with
with the show Bible now will it sell who
knows but someone can see your voice so
if you're just focused on spec spec spec
which I think you have to open it up
because that opens up more opportunities
you know what I mean just to be like
like I said I've written nine TV pilots
too I was paid for and the one was a
comedy and the producer hired me because
I had written a similar comedy the same
kind of humor so my spec which was never
gonna be made no offense to it I used to
get a job which is example of what your
specs will do they'll get you you know
the job for the assignment because what
else do they have to look at your pitch
okay pitches to sell a pitch is you know
difficult but they have to see something
concrete you can pitch until you can
tell you're blue in the face but they're
like okay I want to see unless you've
had something made I want to see what
kind of writing you do here it is oh wow
it's exactly what I envisioned the
comedy from my pilot you got the job so
that's the reason I got the job is
because of the spec now what if I hadn't
had a TV spec and she said oh here's an
opportunity for a job the producer well
you can read one of my features yeah
it's not quite the same I would have
lost the job you know I mean so you have
to have your arsenal you have to have
your stuff and the stuff has to be
really good in the in a professional
level ready to go because when somebody
says hey do you have a blah blah blah
you know yes I do you know even as an
example a few of us are talking about
outlines
earlier and how many outlined their
screenplays before their yeah all right
look at that very nice almost yeah
sometimes yeah yeah that's great yeah
you know yeah i you know i am a militant
about saying do it now because you're
training yourself for when you do get
that job when you do get that assignment
job you won't be like a roach on its
back going hyah
when they say I want it in 30 days sure
how is that possible when you don't at
first they wouldn't let you like I say
every produce I've worked with on
assignment either comes to me with a log
line or they come to me with a one sheet
and they say we need you to do the
treatment it's been I don't think yeah I
don't think I've done I don't think I've
done a project where they handed me a
full treatment and they said right from
that it's always been which I love
because if I get to do the outline
treatment it becomes more of my script
right and more of the elements I get to
put in there and they go yeah I like
that you know because not everything
start out I mean especially when you're
when you're given a one sheet which is
basically one sheet a piece of paper you
know they call it a one sheet and you
could write a script from one sheet it's
very difficult because you know most one
sheet you get or like Act one is this an
act two and then there's the ending and
you're like wow okay and go and and you
know this is important because I think
it was Mickey McKee or someone you know
75% of your work and then you know I
wanted to get into the script the
outline I say is the story of the movie
it's so important to be your roadmap you
wouldn't build a house without the
blueprints right and the script is the
blueprint of the movie so it's like a
pre blueprint and there's beat sheets
there's step outline I've done one that
was 30 pages a step outline so I was
joking
I said add 60 pages you got the movie
but the reason is is because the
director it was a movie where you know
we were shooting
with cell phone footage and then it was
alive it was hard to explain but then we
would cut to surveillance so you know
all these technical things had to be in
the script they weren't just gonna think
of it on the day of the movie like well
what should we shoot you know so that's
why you know it was that extensive but I
was like wow that was the longest but
generally the ones I'm required to do
her by 10 pages you know and it's broken
into acts and I just I write the story
of the movie and there's things in there
I don't really put pieces of dialogue
you can which is helpful because you
know but if you train yourself now to
start doing that those of you don't do
outlines know if you say no no I'm just
saying is that you it's like training
for a marathon you wouldn't just say I'm
gonna run a marathon and then when
you're asked to run a marathon you're
like oh damn I didn't really train again
like I say they require it because
there's the network there's a production
company there's the money people they
all want to see what's going on and they
look at the concept they go oh it's
great
but you got to execute that properly
that thing that they're saying is great
has to be equally as great you know I
mean and you don't want to be on page 45
going huh okay now what happens next and
you haven't written your five pages
today and tomorrow now you're ten pages
behind and now your 15 pages it's just
like it's the worst place to be and you
shouldn't because you can work out all
that crappy stuff in the outline that
you don't want in the screenplay
and then I'll talk about the vomit draft
as well which I don't believe in a vomit
draft deadlines I think is what
separates the pro from the amateur
getting the job done you set up your
your deadlines now as writers you're
training yourself again you know you
don't have an open-ended no matter what
level of the business you're at you
don't have any time someone's paying you
it's not open-ended I think you know
it's raining I don't think I'll I'll go
do this today you don't get your pages
done okay that's fine but like I said
when it comes time to work
professionally that's your job I say say
to writers sometimes I work eight to ten
hours a day and they're like oh I said
yeah but that's my job that's all I do
so I better damn well
doing it you know so you know deadlines
are important like I said and the
hardest thing at first for me was to you
know when you go writing SPAC and
whatever you want to producing on
producing on demand being creative on
demand that was the hardest thing my
brother's a graphic designer and he
always told me that was hardest for him
because you know you're in college
whatever doing your thing and then some
of you get into a real world and now you
have to produce at a certain level on
demand and it takes a certain you know
waiting for the muse or I don't want to
write today no you know when I inked
that contract and the check clears you
got at work today it's your job and so
if you're training yourself now with the
mindset like that you're training
yourself and so it's no big deal where
it's like uh-uh and I understand about
the different you know issues in life
and and you may have children or you
know but if you can keep to like Raymond
Chandler used to sit at his desk every
day regardless if anything happened or
something happened because it's that
that steady that steady that steady is
what's going to do it the discipline WGA
gives you about ten weeks for a first
draft sounds like a lot actually is a
lot I'd love ten weeks three weeks for a
reading period you know the producer has
requirements to so you they just don't
like you didn't give you a script to the
producer they go okay we'll see you in
six months
that's holding you up so they have
reading requirements producers do as
well there's that's three weeks four
weeks for a second draft shorter three
weeks for them to read it and get back
with notes two weeks for a Polish so
that's twenty two weeks just for a
second draft in WGA now the movies I
write have shorter time periods like
that but same thing sometimes I'm given
30 days which is no big deal three three
pages a day is a luxury you know as far
as I'm concerned five pages is okay
that's twenty days for a first draft and
then the last week I can go over the
script myself you know look at
ticky-tack stuff and be confident and
say this is my first draft actually it's
my second you know whatever
so that's why I say in first drafts the
vomit draft this idea about just getting
it down
some people love and believe it I just
want to get it down on paper well you go
back and you find that fifty percent is
crap why waste your time just getting it
on paper you won't have the problem if
you outline and you can deviate from the
outline completely and there's always
you always find good stuff in there once
you start the characters you two guys
are in the scene together okay I put
that down now I still have to write the
scene and I can say what it's about but
there's always some in from ah oh my god
you know once you're in that once you're
in that zone great creative stuff
happens so people said I want to be
stifled by you know that
so just to vomit it out and again as I
say you won't be given that chance to
vomit a draft when you're working you
imagine me vomiting a first draft and
handy to my producer he looks at and
goes what the hell is this and then
starts to think about my question of my
ability and then maybe hire somebody
else to you know come on board which
I've done two other projects which have
been eight drafts so then they're like
this isn't working and you're like okay
and so you go in and you know you mix up
the salad and say well take the cucumber
out that doesn't work and this dressings
too much and you know try to get in
there and and and fix it and if you can
fix it and and get that train back on
the tracks which is what they want to
try to use these analogies to get the
project back in order so they can make
the movie you've become the Savior
you're the writer who's actually saved
the project which is a good thing and
it's an ability to have you know because
rewriting is you know it happens people
so how would you rewrite somebody else's
script somebody has to you know I've
been rewritten yellow you'll get fired
at some point that's just what happens
and if you don't want to do it and and
say well you know then that's okay too
but I'm just saying rewriting work is
available and also helps you it makes
you better writer for your own projects
because you can come to something
without any attachment you know it's not
these are my babies I guess I can
cut the you're just looking at which is
great which a producer does cut this out
you don't need this boom it's hard to do
that with your own stuff but it's a lot
easier with other people's projects and
you can start seeing structurally and
that's how you continue to learn quickly
about format how many use final draft
here at all okay almost everybody great
there are other ones that's fine I'm not
saying you know anything about I'm just
saying professionalism is also about
format I consult on scripts I can tell
from the title page where it says
register WG aw copyrighted you know it's
like if you steal this I'm gonna come
and you know kill your children you're
like yeah just put your name on it in
your contact your you know professionals
do their due diligence and they expect
you to as well so if somebody's really I
had a writing party we would say we
should be so lucky if someone stole our
screenplay we would make more money if
they stole our screenplay then actually
you know and ideas are everywhere so try
to prove that I've been on a million
pitch meetings in the next morning you
know think somebody comes I have a great
idea or a little a little strand goes in
here and it comes out then not that it's
stealing everybody takes and takes from
you know from from everywhere but to
think that somebody's gonna steal your
script and put that on there I'm like
okay maybe you know so I turn to page
one I start to real blocks of text like
this you know you know all sorts of
things that happen it's it's the way I'm
trying to say this is the way the script
reads will give you away you know I'm
saying and you see the readers know you
can't fool them and or if you have a
script and you turn it in it's 120 pages
you know they're gonna have a stack of
reads for the weekend and go okay what
do I know it's a script and a quarter a
script and a quarter of another script
that's 20 2000 gonna get through this
behemoth and they skim read or skim
yeah the skin so so format is important
until you make it like I said I work
with a producer who has no problem with
writing you know with what's in people's
heads or things like that's fine
so I become a chameleon I transfer but
it's a protected bubble because it's in
development so I would say be careful
when you read the Academy scripts or the
award-winning ones because those are all
written in a protected bubble and so
you're reading those and I always say to
writers don't try to emulate that style
because they're getting away with things
that you might not be get away with if
it's a spec from an unknown writer you
understand so I've read some and if I
said if I was consulting on this thing I
would completely tear it apart not
saying that I'm some genius but I would
be like there breaky there are rules but
there's also conventions that people
follow because they read scripts all the
time and you break those break them
later first know them before you break
em first of all so that that's my point
about format and also format it's
important to the read things are flipped
it's hard when I can solve the scripts
I'm trying to read them like I don't
understand that so I'm in a protected
bubble I can go back and study it a
reader is not going to go back and study
it if they have to study things three or
four times this isn't this is hard to
get through is it I don't understand
it's confusing that's gonna kill and if
you think that they're gonna have the
end of that go you know it wasn't well
written but the idea was amazing there's
a million amazing ideas out there and
even if they bought that script they're
gonna fire you and have somebody else
write it so what's the point you know I
mean put your best foot forward when it
comes to that micromanaging kills your
script you have to know what to put in
and leave out which I find my consulting
too too many things that are in there we
described the black piano with the three
thing if steps on the bus why is it even
important that it's here if the piano is
important to the scene or the chandelier
you know leave stuff out that's not
important they're their people's jobs
who's that is to find that stuff it's if
it's terribly important write it if it's
not do not
about your characters you know six feet
tall with you know ten fingers it's more
of what the character is in the
description not so much the visual
because unless it's extremely important
you know what I mean you've read scripts
and know that when you start to read
there's there's there's two sentences to
describe someone you're like what do we
you know okay you're laughing because
you know cut it down not you know we're
not not talking about the past so your
script reads extremely important specs
hard to sell like I said you may write
ten before you sell the first or get it
was my fourth spec that made some noise
we got an a-list actor interested at the
time his big action movie but the
unfortunate it was like an 80 million
dollar budget you know and so that was
kind of like huh but my partner at the
time writing partner was working for the
biggest producer in Hollywood of action
movies at the time so we thought well
we're in right because he works for him
he drives him so at a red light he
pitched him the idea and the producer
goes yeah big big budget big movie and
that's the last we ever heard about it
um but we did go to CAA to meet the the
a-list actors agent of course we had no
representation at the time so we were
bumbling through this you know with a
script I look at now and I'm like yeah
it could have been a lot better and if
it was we probably would it probably
would have been his choice to make so
that that but then the fifth script my
fist spec took seven years to from the
time I wrote it to the time it was made
and he almost won the nickel fellowship
which was an important step because I
was in the top twenty and that year I
think there was thirty five hundred
scripts and now it's up to seven
thousand in nickel and so even not
winning the fellowship which I I'm glad
I didn't because the next year the
script was option and then eventually
made you know it was an accolade that I
could use to tell agents oh I was in the
top 1% of nickel I was you know they
called me and said we picked the nine
but you were in the next 12 and I was
like oh my god you know they said well I
hope you enter it next year but I hope
you don't you know because you're
actually doing something with
and luckily it did but that was enough
to get people interested and said oh but
unfortunately it was a world war 2 movie
with kids and at the time we talked
about marketplace and timing nobody was
making a movie like that you know I had
an agent tell me once Disney's not even
listening to a pitch so I had a company
wanted to do an outright buyout here's
the money
see you later and I'm glad I didn't take
it because you know I was waiting tables
at the time like somebody's offering me
money I'll take it
I didn't take it which which is you know
the choices you make you can only look
back on later but it was the right
choice because it took a bit longer
maybe a few more years but it found the
right company a brand new company that
started and they embraced and said this
is going to be our first film that we
make we want to make these type of
movies that would have never happened
with that other company and by the way
the agent who gave me that advice said
oh and by the way I'll broker the deal
for you the deal that I found and the
company they wanted to buy it outright
you know I was like no thanks I'll I'll
handle this myself and thanks a lot
so you know with your specs you never
know but like I said that opened the
door with that company who was revving a
production to be like well now and you
know you know specs are heavy lifting I
mean it really is to come up with you
know I have good ideas we all do but to
come up with that idea there's a million
ideas out there ideas are as they say a
dime a dozen they are so I know at a
party they go you right don't you I'm
like yeah
and they go umm I guess great idea for a
movie and I always say great write it
and they go no but you're the writer I'm
like okay and so they they pitch the
idea and I'm like huh they said well you
know like it's no offense but is like
the most genius thing you've ever heard
of is it will do something with it and I
say I'm a little busy I got you know I
said why don't you take a crack at it
because they don't like the idea enough
if they like the idea enough they would
write it themselves I mean you know or
if they're not a writer they're pitching
out ideas is if you know I mean I don't
know it's it's interesting that's why
you think you have to think it was
calling cards because
some you know under less than a hundred
specs of your cell so I mean at the
studio level and I don't say all these
numbers and what 50,000 scripts are
registered with the guild and always
bring those numbers up not to scare
anyone to say you know bash my dream no
but respect it you know respect the
mountain that you climb every single day
you know that we all do as writers
trying to claw and Kay and stay and and
gain ground and lose ground you know
that's why I say it's staying in the
game that's the hardest thing you know
making it I think when you get your next
job you make it but there's more
pressure when you write your spec
there's no pressure you know if you have
your day job or whatever you're you
right near your material and that's
great but once you sell something
now there's the pressure to do it again
right and will it happen again that's
the biggest fear you may not happen
quickly
I had a friend whose friend sold a big
movie is a 40 million dollar budget all
actors you would know he never worked
for five years and so you know I mean
you're like well that money doesn't last
that long so my point is yeah you never
know about the specs so patience is
another important virtue never get your
script out as you know before it's ready
never never because it's gonna harm the
project and it's going to harm the image
of you as a writer
and it seems it seems like it would be
logical like of course I wouldn't do
that but I tell you people have given me
there's their scripts and then a week
later they saw I hope you didn't read it
knows you're laughing you know because
you may have never done this I did this
early on and learned it's unprofessional
hope you to read it why not because I
have a new draft then why did you give
me this draft because it wasn't quite
done yet
well when you are done with it don't
give it to people I mean give it to
people only when you're done with it
because some people have started reading
it or like me I get right to it because
you know I like to have integrity you
know you build that by saying I don't
that's why I say no because I have I
have my own work I have you know all the
stuff and then the remainder of my life
that's left you know what I mean and so
when people say
we read my script and if I say no the
I'm just too busy and being honest and
you should appreciate that because most
people in this business want credit for
their good intentions and you've had
this and I've had this where they say Oh
give me your script and then six weeks
later you feel like an ass did you read
it
oh I you know I've just been swamped
then why did you say you would read the
script just say no see nobody likes to
say no they want credit for saying I
told you that I'd read it I want the
credit for that but it's the
follow-through that's the problem
so if you this is how you build your
integrity to with just anybody if you
say I'm going to read your script if to
somebody do it absolutely do it and then
people will know you as a person of your
word and that's extremely important when
people start to hire you is that they
want to know that you're gonna meet the
deadline that you're gonna you know I'm
blessed that I work with producers now
that I've worked with enough that they
just call me and say which happened last
week which is you know a blessed place
to be where they say I have three
projects that are that are okay greenlit
does any one of them appeal to you yeah
pick one okay okay I remember the days
when you know I'd be the person calling
did you read them huh you know and they
go six months late I'm sorry we didn't
get or can't get through the assistant
you know what I mean so but that's
building the relationship which they'll
talk about later it's extremely
important and integrity to know that I
deliver I deliver early and they don't
have to worry about it because when
they're busy doing their thing they
don't want to have to go you know I had
one contract that said they want to see
every 10 pages I was like no I don't
work like that you hired me to write the
script I will write it it'll be ready
when we agreed to in the contract that's
it but I'm not turning in 10 pages to be
running on a treadmill to be write
writing it's not going to happen and so
but once you deliver you just do one
time then it's like oh wow and then you
work twice or three or four then people
start to know your integrity and and
that's what they want because there's a
lot of money at stake so we're talking
about never giving your script out
detach for survival I think
is important because you can't live or
die by every line of dialogue or scene
and it's not worth losing a job for you
know defend when you have to I was
having this conversation recently you
don't want to be a troublesome writer
that even has a whiff of being difficult
because once you're branded difficult
it's hard stench to get off I mean truly
that doesn't mean you can't defend what
you think needs defending I tell the
story that I worked with a producer and
then he was off on another project and
we worked closely on the script and he
handed me over to the executive producer
who I never worked with and they were in
another country so we did a Skype call
and suddenly they started picking apart
the ending of the movie and I was like
oh no no no and I was there I was the
only last line of defense
because if no one had stepped up to say
anything these are big changes which I
thought honestly were not right and so I
you know I said you know what I said my
piece and if you say your piece make
sure you back it up with real details
not just well I felt this way you have
to have concrete like here's why I'm
gonna convince you that what you're
thinking is not the way to go and so I
said my spiel and had my piece and then
there was a silence and I was like not
damn and the executive producer then
said okay all right that's fine moving
on I was like oh all right you know we
got that that battle over with but I
wasn't gonna do it twice you know I was
a good and I and they do appreciate that
you're just not you know as a typist or
scribe or whatever then you're just
gonna be you have to you know you know I
wrote the movie you know I mean you're
changing stuff that maybe on a whim
would just be like oh we thought of this
other no wait psycho whole XYZ but you
know so I think they appreciate that to
a certain point because you're a
collaborator you know not just a robot
where you're just you know in fact and
just have a machine write the script
which I serve someday they'll figure out
so you also have to when you start
working executing notes is extremely
important
and you get that a little when you write
your specs from your like writers groups
or people who read it or consultants but
it's a whole different ballgame when
you're giving you're getting notes from
producers and many times producers don't
know how to talk with writers and you
expect them to do that but I've worked
with some that just don't have that
shorthand or they they talk in broad
strokes and you're trying to get them
down to like understand what without
acting like you don't know what you're
doing or you're asking too many
questions you know the famous funny line
is the note I got is you know the the
emotional highs and lows have to be
higher and lower okay all right good you
validate parking it's like what page
what are we talking about every single
emotional high and low that's sort of
like a broad stroke where you go well
what are we talking about here you know
and other producers I worked with or you
know you get your your notes and it's
page 13 blah blah blah and you just go
through the checklist and start making
the changes and hopefully they're not a
lot of changes but executing notes is
another important thing when you start
working and it's just it's just from
doing but it's listening and and when
you work with anybody if first time you
have to see their style you know
producers done 100 credits you know
you're working with they have you got to
almost really play catch-up and if you
don't you know you don't want to be seen
as I mean when you're rusher threw at
the door maybe you could ask an
assistant but you got to nail that down
in the room if you're if you're having a
meeting with them about a notes meeting
and really know and then listen to who
has the authority to give you notes
because I've had assistants sit there
and go hey you know what I've got a
great idea
and I'm like hi I'm like mmm and you
know they want to make themselves look
good in front of the producer which I
understand but I'm like yeah okay and I
write the note down I'm like that's
really not gonna happen
you know I'll listen to it but you know
and I didn't really agree with them mmm
so you have to go to bat for that no
this is not to a certain point yeah it
all depends on how how much willing
you're willing to fight and how much
Willie they're willing to go huh
this is too this is too hard we want it
to be easy but if you really believe in
it then go for it you know what I mean
but you're gonna get notes from
everybody you know you give a scrip to
anybody in the room everybody's going to
do a different opinion about it a
different take now if five people have
the same opinion you'd be like huh okay
well maybe I should make this change but
if everybody's gonna and the notes I
like the best are not the ones will I do
it this way it's like this doesn't work
I see what you're trying to do and
that's what I try to do one in my
consulting I don't say I would do it
this way I would say oh you're almost
close if you just did this then I I'm
not trying to change it but you know I
mean I'm trying to help what you've
already created that might you might
have missed a little bit you know or
something it just doesn't work and
here's the reason why it doesn't work
but hopefully again solid outline
working with people before it becomes a
faster process believe me in some recent
films that it's been a really fast
process and I think it's I'm not trying
to Pat myself in the back but it's it's
because of the collaboration that's key
if you don't like to collaborate or you
don't like criticism don't type fade in
really wrong business to be in if you
write a novel because then it's exactly
the way you know what you want but
you're working with other creative
people and money that's not yours or
theirs and you know a lot of different
factors so not to say you can't do good
stuff you know but and then the chasing
notes you can chase your tail forever
I've done that before you like you got a
thing oh yeah you're right but you gotta
ah and you and then you dilute it so
much you'd even know anymore what you
want or what I don't know what to
believe
that's the worst place to be because
then you then you're totally lost the
best place to be is why call where
you're written out where you're like
goodnight folks
that's it and you're sonal totally
confident and
like this has been through the mill the
ringer and I will stand by this live or
die by the script and send it out come
what may
that's a great place and I've been there
before with specs where you've worked on
it so much take an input and you will
feel confident about it and then who
knows even then but it doesn't matter
because it's what your feeling is and
that'll that'll show that confidence and
then you go okay and then once they buy
it then they can you know shred it and
tear it apart and you know after the
fact we take a break in a few minutes
oh we're good here adapt I had to become
a faster writer like I said because the
jobs offer offered to me I could have
said no to but you have to adapt you
know I mean you know and I wasn't say I
wasn't a fast writer but I had to become
a faster writer and also right at his
particular level fast and like I said
the hardest thing when I first started
was to be able to produce on demand
which is what it's about when you're
hired this is not playing around and go
and Saturday I think you know I'll go to
the beach you know that's fine as long
as you can do your quota of pages the
next day go to the beach
have fun have at it you know but when
it's time to work its work so I I admit
I was hung up that phone I was like what
did I just do what I did is kick myself
in the ass to be you know to push myself
out of my comfort zone which is
extremely important that's how you grow
as a writer you don't grow by staying
you know safe or doing your same thing
over again you got to go I may fall on
my face and I may not you know I wasn't
gonna not meet the deadline but I wanted
to meet the deadline with with something
that was great you know something that
was like I could say here it is and they
go oh man okay and then and by the way
we have another thing oh you have it you
know and another one you know that's
that's how you become a working writer
is not just one sale but the next one
and then becomes like I said the
pressure of having to do it again and
then again and again and I gotta get it
you know and and there are dry periods
as well like I said I'll tell the story
about going to law firm that's the
hardest thing once you're in the
business and then you go back to
something that you don't want to do and
then you're they're going on it's really
commenced with your head is if you allow
it so I said about all these
crazy numbers with the scripts you know
50,000 registered at the guild every
year you know that's why you have to
have multiple projects in the
marketplace I think at all times so you
have one script out there this is
working that one is over at this company
good stuff I mean not just but the more
horses you have in the race one of them
is gonna you know maybe come in third
but at some one point it's gonna come in
you know first and something's gonna
happen and then I found it comes in
waves either it's dry spell and then oh
my gosh there's so much work and then uh
or it's just like that you know it it
comes and goes you don't know it but but
the more projects you have out there the
more opportunities you create because
every script you write is another
opportunity that you're creating you
know to showcase your talent to showcase
the project like I said don't expect it
to sell but it might but what it what
doors that it can open and what Jabba
doors can open like I said with that
with that rewrite job what doors think
bigger you know not that you don't I'm
just saying from my experience I used to
think smaller and I realized I had to
think bigger you know to open it up more
because because there's million people
out here doing the same thing and not
here just around the world I think I
read a statistic two million people
writing screenplays in the world or some
crazy you know some number but who cares
about the numbers right okay so but the
numbers forget the numbers so and then
lastly before the break I say if you can
find a mentor or an apprentice that's
great I've been lucky that directors
I've worked with you know I've written a
script with the company and they say now
we have the director coming on board and
then I'm due notes so they're showing
I'm showing them how I can work with
them and they start to get to know me
now they become a friend and a mentor
and then we separate because they
they've made the film that I wrote and
then they go hey you know I've got this
idea we want to work on so then we now
have our own things from that one
project has spawned a mentor or you know
and then also an equal collaborator so
it's a fantastic learning experience you
know sometimes
writers you know pay for assistance and
so it's a good way to be going to
meetings one time a director who was a
writer wanted to hire me as his
assistant
actually he worked in the I worked in a
restaurant he his office was upstairs so
he come down and we you know chitchat
and he said I want to give you a job it
never happened but he hated to sit at
the keyboard you know he didn't he
didn't like to write that way he liked
to walk around so I would be the guy at
the keyboard and then I would go into
meetings with him and he may imagine
having that inside you know information
that you that you don't normally get and
get paid for it so I mean that's a good
way to and then also when you finish
your script you can hand it to your
mentor say you can take a look at this
you know a mentor goes oh it's great you
know are things that you just learn you
know that mentorship kind of thing I
don't know if it's a thing of the past
but I know it happened more in the past
and it's hard to define but the mentors
I've had have been people that I've been
blessed to work with and then we've had
friendships you know along the way as
collaborators so you get to see a
business from the inside so that is
basically it for that section we take a
little break five-minute break and come
back and talk about quickly the
screenwriters life writing partners all
sorts of fun stuff okay going back to
screen or his life your talent is
extremely important but it's not the
only thing that's gonna get you your
break you know it's timing also and like
I said I wrote a script my first my
fifth spec my first one that I sold the
timing was all off because Hollywood was
not making that type of movie that
particular historical genre film except
one company years later was but I didn't
give up but I didn't just stop with that
script you know what I'm saying you know
I continued to write other specs and and
it almost winning the Nicholl fellowship
kind of helped to open some doors so you
know I say the the way that that
happened was my girlfriend at the times
friend was an assistant and this is
important to be friend assistants
because they're not always going to be
as
and they're looking at the rolodex of
the boss to go on to be a producer if
the boss is a producer right so the
assistant said I like marks script I
want to do something with it
and here I was like of course but she
couldn't do something with it and so her
friend had the same idea and took the
script and he could do something with it
he got it to his boss and they were
about to make a brand new company and so
the boss said that and every system
wants to bring in a good project to
their boss right and he said that's the
kind of script that we want to make and
at first they didn't want to option it
they said well make some changes and we
might I was a little of we might I said
no I I don't need to sell this thing and
that's this thing you can't be desperate
you know a lot of writers are hanging on
desperate I gotta sell this script cuz I
gotta you're trying to sell a script to
make your rent or a house payment you're
insane I mean I mean and trust me I've
tried I've been there years ago but you
can't think that way because I'm telling
you seven years and that's not every
spec is that that in that way but I use
it as an example that every script you
write as a spec is going to have its own
journey and it's gonna take its own time
and sometimes even if it is you know
purchased and made it's a step deal so
like I said you know you're gonna get
when you read about the million dollar
sale no one hands the writer a million
dollars that movie still has to be made
you know it's a step deal it steps
here's the tears to start here's for the
first draft there's for the rewrite step
step step as the money gets smaller and
smaller and so like I mentioned those
five scripts of mine that are on the
Shelf that's money on the table because
those bonuses are not ever going to be
seen I mean you know we hope but and you
know some of them were written years ago
and like I said one one actually might
be made but you don't get the bonus till
the movie goes into production so a lot
I think times writers who don't aspiring
writers don't understand how the
payments are doled out you know and when
they are doled out it's important for
you to be able to live you know within
your means and that's an important thing
too if you get a good chunk of money
just don't go out and blow it like it's
be coming all the time you know what I
mean so I say that live within your
means and I think it's a good idea
anyway but especially when you don't
know now if you're on a TV show and
you're locked in to do you know 13
episodes you know where your money's
coming from but even when you sell it a
script you don't know that you're gonna
get that second the opportunity for the
second draft and you may be fired and
then have to show the credit and now
you're looking for another job
definitely not with the producer fired
you and not with now word has gotten
around that you would let go you know
what I mean it's like so live within
your means
like I said every scripts a new
opportunity always go above and beyond
the call of duty you know even when you
think there's first jobs not for a lot
of money treat every job it's the way I
do with no matter I did crazy odd jobs I
delivered pizza waited tables cleaned
apartments all all odd jobs I did the
best to my ability for each job because
that's the way I know that's the way I
can do it and so what I'm saying is your
first jobs might not be for a lot of
money or might not be what you expected
you might be throwing a rewrite for very
little money and go and be blessed to be
thankful be grateful because you never
know that your opportunity to knock it
out of the park and and now you're in
working and you've solidified that
relationship they're gonna remember you
know I spoke to one writer I ran into
and I ran into him in the circles and he
always said ah I'd never share credit
with anybody he was like I said really I
told him that I had this opportunity for
a rewrite job and you know if I had come
on board I'd share credit because I was
changing enough of the script and his
ego just basically said he'd never share
credit with anybody I said okay that's
fine that's that's your choice just know
that when you start to say no enough
there are other people who would do the
job and have the opportunity and so you
know everybody has their own thing if
you want to hold out for the thing
that's okay take your take
responsibility for your choice as a
screenwriter as an artist you know
because
no one forced any of us to do this you
know when I was 11 years old no one put
a gun in my I said you're gonna be a
tree you know damn you was gonna be a
filmmaker now I was blessed to have
parents who were creative types but
never got to do it for a living and so
they told my brother and I always go for
your dreams and I never I always say
never put an expiration date on my
dreams and that's good and bad because
you can drag it out to be like wow I
don't see any success and it's been 20
years or you know everybody has their
breaking point and you have to find that
you only will find that by being in it
for a number of years and taking a lot
of blows and successes and that's I
always say you know cherish the little
successes along the way if an agent
reads your script or you know you may
not think it doesn't always have to be
the big giant thing because all those
little things add up and before you know
it sudden you're like oh my gosh I got a
job and now I have another job and I
cultivated that into this and so these
little successes it's not like what I
used to think maybe some of you do like
overnight your life will change you'll
sell something overnight my gosh you
know food will taste better you know the
air will smell better you still have the
same problems as a human being you still
have the same things and yeah you may
have but you're just getting to live
your dream you know which has always
been my goal is to like you know wake up
in the morning and do what I love for a
living I mean it's the greatest kick in
the world and to finally get to a point
where and I still get nervous with a new
project
of course I do I don't take it for
granted you know what I mean because I
had parents who didn't like their jobs
you know like I said before most people
work for the weekend and I didn't want
to have a life like that even though
it's been a struggle it's been hard and
difficult but like I said staying in the
game you know that friends are actors
who yeah I want to be an actor you know
I'd love to you know and then they
didn't study or they didn't continue
doing their thing or like us writers
they didn't continue to write you know
shame on you if you're not writing
absolutely because there are people out
there right now while we're here
who
banging away writing is harder than
you'll ever imagine because they want it
more and that's okay
because somebody's gonna go out and live
their dream right but why not why not
you why not us right so I I don't know
getting up in the morning doing that is
is what my parents always wanted and
they knew that there would be no
guarantees and it's tough in a business
where there are no guarantees even after
you sell something like I said even if
when you're paid to write something no
guarantee but you put it out there you
know so that's why saying in the concept
of the bigger picture
what screenplay you're writing now is
going to affect your time which you
don't get back it's your most priceless
precious commodity is your time and
that's why when you're writing you have
to protect your writing schedule from
distraction and procrastination
procrastination usually comes from fear
and like oh well you know this has seems
hard and I'll just go fur I'll go see a
movie you know not good maybe good then
maybe you'll get an idea from that but
you do that for two days or three and
now the projects in a drawer and like I
said I've had the day job for two years
but you have to be a master once you're
working to set up your own schedule in
your own life which is difficult because
when you have all this free time it's
not free you're burning it but also if
you have a deadline you got to learn how
to juggle your time well and that's the
first thing they had to learn like oh my
gosh now I don't have to punch it like
how I do have to punch a time clock
because I got to sit down to write but
maybe it could be at 10:00 this morning
or maybe it could be pushed till till
noon and I'll now write till 8:00 p.m.
as long as the works done you know what
I mean like I said before don't put
yourself out if you're not ready take
chances no gain but be smart
don't be stupid about it you know what I
mean set up a master plan and stick to
it but change and adapt when necessary
like I say keep an eye in the bigger
picture keep reevaluating where you're
at because time goes by so fast and in
Hollywood its Hollywood's time nothing
ever ever ever is gonna happen as fast
as you or I want it a simple contract
trust me can go back and forth for three
or four weeks and you're like I got to
get
that check I gotta get paid well okay
the lawyer now is on vacation and there
was a holiday they threw in and you know
things take time I mean it's not like
overnight someone calls start to work
you know so you have to be aware aware
of that as well
networking absolutely vital the final
draft has get-togethers in town script
writers network is a good organization
to join they have free I did a speaking
engagement November last year if you're
a member the speaking engagements are
free if not they're like thirty dollars
is a international screenwriters
association that's another good one
and stage thirty two I don't know if
you're familiar with that very good
networking from people all over the
globe
oh so networking is vital and like I
said assistants are great if you happen
to know because they're not going to
bond it be assistants forever and every
assistant wants to bring their boss a
terrific piece of material and that
could be yours hopefully like it was
with mine out there was terrific but you
know be a good contact this is important
it's not about take take take give give
give and people remember absolutely they
remember that people I've done things
for years later go hey remember you know
when you did that thing it was no big
thing it was a big thing one phone call
can change something you know and it's
just about being now you have to do it
to the right people you wouldn't suggest
someone who's not going to deliver the
you know the goods I've had people refer
me to others but they did only because
they knew that they could trust me
because that reflects back on them you
know I'm saying so you only want to
refer to someone who you really trust
and I've done that before as well
because I knew the person was solid and
it wasn't gonna burn me so yeah that
person you sent me really you know
messed up the work so really I'm sorry I
can't send him another person right
because they start to it starts a
question my you know ability
keep your creative well full which means
living an authentic life outside your
comfort zone and so like I said when I
had was forced to be a faster writer it
was time you know maybe I was resting on
my like well I can just you know now
would I have done it before then
probably not but you don't know when
you're going down this this journey what
what you're gonna be forced into and
what you take and say yeah I did it and
now you have that confidence to do that
but you're creative well means living an
authentic and interesting life that
means traveling
it means interacting with people it
doesn't mean just sitting in your room
making stuff up what you have to do
that's our job as writers but your
interesting stuff in your life is
researching me how great is that that
our jobs are to live interesting lives
you know because that's what we put in
our stuff it makes it authentic not not
regurgitated stuff that you've seen
before on the screen that comes out as
cliched and inauthentic because you're
just perpetuating another cliche that
goes on and on rather than saying this
actually happened to me and somehow you
work that into your character that makes
it interesting different you know and I
think that's that's our job to do that
and how fun you know what I mean you can
say I'm not sure you can write off your
trip to Rome just because you said well
you know I was doing research on Italy
but you know what I mean read books
scripts blogs watch and study films I
think may have you seen the film courage
videos but that kind of stuff you know
what I mean I'm always reading and
looking and finding new article always
learning I learned on every screenplay
even after 36 every screenplay learned
something new I learned how to work with
somebody new always learning and I you
know Hemingway said we're all we're all
was it we're in a craft where no one
ever becomes a master I think was his
quote and I was like wow because you
listen to a jazz musician who's 80 and
says I'm still learning it's like yeah
you're right this is an ongoing process
it's not just like well I know
everything I'm done okay great you don't
and if you do think that way you're
going to be humbled quite quickly
and keep hitting that wall if like why
am I not getting something over the wall
you know and so be cognizant of of you
know all these things read what's going
on in the trades if you have people in
the business it's really important to
have the inside year and that helps when
you're writing something that's already
out there I call it the specter of
similar ideas I don't know if this
happened to you but you're writing a
spec and you finish it and go yay and
then you learn that there already is a
spec out there and it's with people who
are established and now whose idea do
you think is going to sell that happened
to my writing partner and I we wrote a
spec and we found out that an a-list
actor was always interested in playing
this character and it was a real life
character DB cooper who hijacked an
airplane in 1971 and so yeah it was a
news article okay but we wrote a script
and we're gonna go out with a big push
and we found out that this a-list actor
already had a project set up and he
always wanted to play DB Cooper and we
were just like oh are you kidding me
he better to find that out before we
spent six months on the script right but
okay learning experience but you know
would I rather spent six months writing
something else it was more viable sure
but you get crushed many times by the
similar ideas or similar projects that
we already have or they say where you
have something like that development and
you're like well it's not exactly the
same yeah but it has a drone in it right
but ours is not about drones you know
sometimes there's very short sightedness
where it's like we already have
something similar you're like it's not
similar but you can't say that you can't
try to convince them as an adult oh yeah
there was one called the search for DB
Cooper I think and they the one with
this particular actor no he never he
never did and we never did obviously
either script contests anybody enter
contests which ones script pipeline yeah
oh great okay fantastic
so it's
gulia then okay now anything come from
that Oh fantastic it's good to hear okay
anything come from yeah the contests are
good like I said Nikhil is a top one and
you know not winning it actually was a
better thing because the film was made
but if you can place in one of the high
ones like like final draft big break
screen craft script uh Palooza page you
know the big ones when you start getting
into the smaller ones like you know
Joe's potato couch potato not to bash
them but it really doesn't matter if you
win that because you're gonna bring that
and they go what is that again you you
have to really you know and there's a
million contests out now everybody's got
a contest Rhode Island thing this thing
and you have to read the fine print
because many of these contests is not
many but some are actually if you win
they own the rights to your screenplay
so you have to really be careful about
you know just throwing your 75 bucks
away you know I would say the top five
ones picked those and you know stick
with those but again I know this writer
and he keeps every year sending any ski
can't get past the thing and I'm like
why do you keep trying after four times
you can't get past the thing because he
thinks the next one's gonna be it I'm
like okay you're spending your money and
even a friend of mine placed third in
one of the big contests and he got to
meetings and that was it so it's not
contest have to be looked at as another
tool but just because you win doesn't
mean you know some of them you are the
toast of the town they parade you around
and that's great but I I would say I
mean and it is a good way but just be
careful of all the other ones where you
can waste your money and it doesn't
really mean if you win yeah it went to
or fifty dollars to the Joe's couch
potato thing great so you show that to
an agent he's like I don't even know
what this is I mean no offense to it but
the big ones are gonna matter because
they're gonna take you in their tutelage
and make make noise for you
you know I mean final draft page nickel
Austin scripted Palooza
script pipeline scream swing craft has a
lot of different genre ones yeah they've
grown immensely I know John who started
that back and before they were now
they're like going to China and having
huge things it's great so production
savvy screenwriter I have a movie
shooting this weekend starting very
blessed and I will be going to the set
during when they shoot it because it's
always fun and it's a great experience
and it's it's a chance to always learn
because when you're stuck in your bubble
you've got to learn the real production
realities if you're gonna stay on
through the end which is extremely
important to stay on through the end you
don't want to be the writer on the
second draft they go see you later and
then you know you want to be through the
end through development and end up being
the one and and you know that's if
you're doing the right work and properly
up to level you will stay on and I've
been the one who has come in on the
second one and been the person but it's
it's a great experience because you
really see the the the down-and-dirty
laboratory live shooting of a movie
which is a lot different because the
things you're envisioning you may not
have the set that they go out to figure
you know and go location scouting this
and that and just the realities of the
compromise that have to be done you know
I mean where you just don't have
unlimited amount of time and a limited
money and you know I was on the set
doing rewrites but I was also in the
movie because the director wanted me
there so I got to go to Hawaii and spend
two weeks there and that was great
because I was on the set and I only
worked two days as an actor with the
leads which is fantastic but the
direction I want you there so I'm gonna
put you in movies an actor and they'll
pay your way is the actor and I go great
two weeks in Hawaii not a bad gig right
so I'm on the set and I've got four
scenes with the leads who are like you
know I've done some acting but these are
actors who've had shows and movies and
they know their you know their proper
light and it was it was fret you know
nerve-wracking but it was amazing you
know and during the scene the director
was in the video village so he they
couldn't hear him so he said get out
there and and take the sides and run the
thing and so I went in and I was reading
the script that I read and he cut he
yelled action and my voice was the voice
of the PA system and when I read when I
said okay now the whole room erupted it
was in a submarine and so it was amazing
as a writer to sit there and as if you
were all actors like okay now the depth
charge hits boom everybody freaks out
and I go okay another boom you know and
it was amazing because and that director
again us working together now a mentor
and you know these are kind of things
those are the great high points that you
work for and then there's also many
takes years to get to those those points
so like I said it's vital to be the
writer who sees the project to the end
because your personality is also
important people if you're in a TV room
they want to know that you're not some
crazy person that they can't work with
for six weeks or you know six months or
on a feature you know I mean it's the
same thing have a great personality be
someone that you know you and be a
collaborator that's what it's all about
is collaboration
give-and-take good ideas some of the
best lines and one of my movies the the
lead actor Academy Award nominee always
gets the biggest laugh he thought of
that on the set and people was turned to
me go then I go no it's him and totally
given him the credit but I created the
scene so it's not about you did I did
you know what I mean it's just it's a
collaborative thing and if you don't
want to collaborate again it might not
be the best kind of business to be in
we're talking about meetings you know
general meeting pitch meeting if you
have anyone bent on pitch meetings yeah
they're nerve-racking you know and
usually you do the round-robin where you
pitch pitch pitch especially if you have
an agent then they send out your spec
when I had a writing partner
our agents sent the speck out to 40
companies on Wednesday and Friday we
were supposed to have the phone ring off
the hook you know for the big sale well
Friday the phone didn't ring and so
Monday becomes very you know well you
got some meetings okay but it didn't
sell so now that script is a door
stopper you know it's like that's dead
so you go out to the round-robin
meetings with some good people
executives and whatnot vice-president
whatever and they go well we really like
that script what else do you have and
you're supposed to do you know the tap
dances spin the plates again and pitch
them something else or more importantly
have something not there but say I have
this other project which is kind of
similar oh great
send it over what you don't want is not
to have that other project where you're
gonna is what we're gonna hear from you
at six months you know they're gonna
forget all about you at that point so
you want it that's why I say you got to
have those projects ready to go when you
do that pitch because that's how it
works you go out you have the general
meeting or the pitch meeting they say
what else you got here I hit you and you
keep and then when that doesn't go
through you pull back you write
something else and then go around again
and hopefully one of those times they
say hey we have something on a shelf we
need rewritten or they say we want your
perfect they always would say to my
writing partner at the time say you guys
have the perfect tone for this kind of
movie you know that was important to the
tone of the movies that we wrote back to
what genre do you write and is anyone
written scripts with partners one script
are like have a writing partner yeah now
writing part I've only had one no I've
had a few of my life yeah so it's like a
it's like a marriage you know it's a
business and a creative relationship and
you have to be on the same page
you can't be like George Costanza you
know he says we're not taking it it was
just on the other night he says and
we're done and he walks out he goes I'm
so sorry about him you know imagine that
happening
yeah it's a show about nothing it's not
about nothing you know my writing
partner and i were to Leo's so you think
we would like there wouldn't be enough
room in the room for us but it wasn't
the case because we know our strengths
and weaknesses and I let him be the PT
Barnum's showman and I was the one who
was grounded and knew who we were
meeting with I could say you know in the
movie that you know researched their
credits which is always important and
respectful when you go to a meeting know
who you're meeting with look him up
because they might look you up I was in
a meeting recently and they had already
looked me up if I was referred and the
director there was looking me up on the
table and I said I think I know your
credit and he brought up his hundred
credits I'm like oh yeah right you know
sorry I didn't look I didn't know you
were gonna come at the meeting I didn't
you know but know who you're meeting
with it's respectful and also it's a
good thing to be able to talk about
cinema and film because if you can't
talk about movies they're like what are
you even doing here you know dude is it
some fluke that you got to script
through and we bought it but you're not
staying on because you can't you know
execute the notes like I said so and
there's the development meeting and of
course the pitch meeting which is always
nerve ride it'd my best pitch meeting
ever at a big company as a few years ago
and it was out-of-body experience
because it was so good and I and I was
like I was sitting next to myself going
who is this guy I mean I was on fire
I mean couldn't they were asking the
right questions it was just it was
amazing and after it was over they were
never gonna buy it but they I didn't
embarrass myself I said thank you very
much I left I called my manager and she
was like oh I wish I had been there with
you was so exciting I go it was it was
truly one of those and before the
meeting they made me wait in the lobby
for like 20 minutes and it was
nerve-racking because it really puts you
off you know spins you around so act
like a pro always be early and also send
a handwritten note after your meetings
this is extremely important because
nobody does this it's old-school don't
send the email going thanks write a
handwritten note and and I learned that
the assistants put the handwritten ones
on the top male so your notes gonna get
there
in a week later they're gonna open it up
and go huh you know I remember branding
you know and just put you right in their
mind again saying hey thank you very
much not like you know with a $20 bill
or something there you know but just
like hey thank you for the meeting for
taking your time I appreciate it and I
hope you know to see you again soon
that's it no gushing you know craziness
you'll always find your own work as far
as representation that never ends even
when you have a manager an agent I've
had both I've had at mid-level level
agencies agents always seem like they're
they'll only go out with a script when a
manager sort of like you know will say
it's okay
you know managers with you a longer haul
my managers always find the agent that's
the thing once and once you find a
manager they usually come out of
production or they come out of
development and they wanted to produce
agents can't produce by law but agencies
package so it's kind of a weird thing
but managers then once they work on the
script with you and they have knowledge
of you know development they say I think
we're ready to find you an agent that's
when the agent comes into play where
they say I know a good agent we can go
to and so with my writing partner back
in the day this is what happened our
manager found the agent who stuck with
us for three scripts and then he cut us
loose because we didn't sell one
probably because you know agents have
bosses as well and what are you spending
time on the writers that aren't you know
I've got ten clients and five are not
working and you're number fourteen out
of the ten and it's called a hip pocket
client and so you've heard of that term
that means that you're in the hip pocket
you're not signed but you can go around
and say well you know call my agent Fred
at CAA and Fred will take their call and
but no one's daily pushing to try to get
you work you know it's yeah it's a kind
of thing you know it's sort of like you
know it's good I mean something happens
but they're sort of like you know we got
a lot of hip pocket people and we don't
really have to focus on them so it's a
good thing
but just be aware of it
development hell like I've mentioned you
could get stuck in it one time at a
professor at UCLA that's all she wasn't
is in development hell she never sold
anything it was just you know made money
but that was it so we talked about the
step yeah yeah we're open it up you're
first learning and let's say let's say
you've done the work you have a bunch of
good scripts you maybe won a couple of
words what's the best what's the next
step is it better to get a manager first
or an agent I think a manager manager is
the best person to start with an
uncredited unknown writer you go to an
agent like a middle-level or bigger in
my opinion personal they're not gonna
have time to try to break a new writer
it's too difficult send you around and
be like who is this person I've got ten
people who aren't working they want to
have a product that's late they want you
to find something and say oh my god Brad
Pitt I found wants to do my movie Oh
Mike please come in you know so but
you're always you're always doing your
own work always trying to find even when
you have reps you're always networking
that's the most important thing is
networking you understand so any
questions they yes they're in a way sure
I got an email recently for someone has
said do you know a producer director who
can help me with my script that's not
that's not appropriate you know it's
like who are you and why you even send
me this email
I'll help someone that I know and and
like the material because I'm putting my
own reputation out there too we just
like I say with agents you have to
understand when they send you to all of
their people they're putting their
reputation on the line you say you send
me this crazy person you know what's
going on or somebody so when they're
gonna play that hand they don't play it
that many times like with our agent
after three times he was done playing
that you know how many times do we send
these guys around when they're not
they're not selling and you know but
yeah there is appropriate way like like
an example I mean you would say
yeah just be respectful and don't expect
I think don't expect anything from
anybody is the key but have something if
you're going to ask make sure that you
have the goods to back it up that's what
I say because you're gonna get one shot
if you approach someone and say I've got
this thing and it's not quite ready you
know I have hands that I have yet to
play and I'm only gonna play and when
I'm absolutely sure to draw in that
favor you know what I mean yeah are you
like from my situation like I've been
riding for four years right but in the
house you mean not out networking right
oh you go to what I said all these
networking events and script
screenwriting network has them like
every Friday and they're at a hotel and
everyone meets is packed and bump up up
but you know you start making us those
contacts and I'm not sure if producers
are there but you know you'll you'll run
into some or just be out I mean this
town you throw a rock and you run into
somebody my friend bumped into somebody
oh you're one of the biggest producers
and town's assistant so he's like hey
and he's got the gift of gab so he's
like hey my friends a writer you know
I'm like you know yeah you know you
never know but you just approach someone
properly I mean properly you know I mean
just you know what I mean but but you're
talking about those networking things
those are good for getting in that mix
you know people so yeah show Bible is
like it consists of the whole like the
first season all the characters they
want to see you know the mistake you can
make is to write a pilot and then turn
it in and then they read it and go great
I really like to see where this goes and
you go I don't have anything else you
have to have the first season mapped out
the characters their interactions with
each other
little and you know there's no I mean
you can find examples online but there's
a million different kind of exam
but as long as you have the amount of
information to show them where this this
concept is going and can it go for like
seven years or something are we gonna
have a ten year show on our hands or you
don't have any more ideas for these
characters you know and so you have the
first season mapped out in a synopsis
character profiles and then you know
little lines about what each episode is
about you know so you just look online
show Bible no but they're very it's
funny because you got a dig they're very
secretive there's one online from
Battlestar Galactica which is like crazy
you've seen that one right but otherwise
you go there's plenty of scripts online
pilot scripts but to show Bibles that
really like I know nobody wants to show
what it's about it's very secret you
know even if the show is over I don't
know why yeah so there is no set format
that wrote a series Bible yeah scented
and I haven't gotten any comments on the
series Bible at all so it's just those
basics I mean there's you know and
overview yeah the overview you know the
character profile right that was three
pages and then every step aside for the
first third kids yeah sounds pretty
extensive to me right and no comments at
all is awaiting you next we actually
heard Monday you're gonna hear in the
next two weeks again waiting see that's
that's there's long expanses of time I
want to hear tomorrow well you'll hear
in a month you know kind of coming out
for that oh sorry I I really okay
the timing needs to be right so what's
the current market place like well the
movies that are coming out now were you
know made year and a half ago so I mean
you know if you're looking to follow
trends oh I just have an example sorry
about budget ever we saw get out okay
that was a four and a half million
dollar budget film and it grossed I was
completely astonished 255 million
worldwide that's 56 times its budget
four million dollar film four and a half
a million so would you rather try to
write a big tent pole summer movie that
we'd all love to write and then you
write your thing and say here's 100
million dollar it or write more of an
indie film then even have to be for it
could be 1 million now maybe the pay
isn't this great but if you're trying to
swing to that you know you know how many
75 scripts a year or so you know you
know so timing I don't know I mean you
again you write what you want to write
but look at the horror movies are always
popular I don't know which on where you
like to write but everybody's going to
Netflix I love everybody says we'll just
go to Netflix to pitch it ok they got a
lot of money but it's not that easy to
get into Netflix everybody's trying to
do I've got people who were established
going weird you're gonna get in Netflix
ok when is that gonna happen you know it
does happen they have a lot of money you
know but just because doesn't mean
they're gonna say buy everything you
know it's another opportunity in another
place to go if you can get in you know
sorry hey I was wondering so for
assignments
or first night trips whenever you're
going in for your first shaft what what
are some tips you have to stay on for
the second draft or later and also from
the flipside if you are coming in as the
rewriter yeah what is it that made them
you know let go the first writer in the
first place and how do you not make
those mistakes to stay on and not be
another person I got fired most of the
time is that they didn't they didn't
execute what was sold so the outline
that was given they didn't they they
couldn't execute it to the ability of
like wow this is not that good you know
and and like I say the first drafts I
have to turn in can't be a four or five
it has to be like an eight and it should
be because I've got the thing to work
with right if I'm turning in a five all
right we'll do a second draft and you
know try to get it you know but if
you're turning in something that's like
not even there then they could you know
okay we'll give me another shot you know
and okay and then a third one all right
well we got some time give you another
shot and then after that they're like
you're now impeding the development and
we have a start date and people who want
the things so we have to say goodbye and
it's sometimes it's a firing and
sometimes it's we're gonna bring in
somebody else it's sort of like a nice
little like but thank you very much
thank you we'll see it the screening
maybe look for your credit maybe and
yeah and so coming in as a rewriter when
I'm given something it's hard because
when I read that draft but I can be
totally objective because it's not my
script so I can look at it too and go oh
you know what did she but they're saying
here's what doesn't work they have their
own notes about what this is not what
working so go back to this you know go
back to the original thing and fix it
and so a lot of times you can have 40
pages that you may be able to use the
names you know the title obviously
things but then you've got to suss out
the route the other 60 pages and then
sort of weave it back into place and
other times it's like you can't use any
of this I mean there's nothing to
salvage which is the hardest because
you're basically writing a brand new
script
I mean essentially but it's it's a good
it's a job but it's also a good way to
learn structure and it the best way to
learn about something is what is for
somebody else's mistakes your mistakes
too but when you look at something go
god that was just and then some of your
own ideas of what you think is wrong
matches with the producers so you're all
in the same and sometimes say here what
do you think's wrong with this and then
you read it and sell them and they say
okay you know so I mean you start to get
now again I've turned down stuff because
I was just like that's just too much
stuff you know what I mean it's not I'm
gonna say I'm gonna pass you know but
you know I passed too many times yeah
[Music]
yeah that's the million dollar question
it's happened from companies I've worked
with before so they could see that I
could write anyway and and turn out
material and then they would say oh we
need this polished or this fixed so you
just have to have that one that one
break you know what I mean that one
chance for somebody and you and you
shine you know what I mean that's why I
say about every opportunity you have you
have to shine because you never know
when it's like you're the one who did it
you saved the production and then now we
have the you know we also we have in the
fall we got this other thing and now
you're you know now you're working with
these people on a regular basis is what
how you become a working writer I was
rewritten because I had never worked
with a producer and I'm not defending
myself but we he was they he didn't
think I could do the work in the time
table and so they just said you know
we're gonna have somebody else come in
and it wasn't like it wasn't a complete
rewrite it sort of and and these are new
notes that were coming in which you know
what I mean so but yeah it's it's
happened and then the job you have
oh yeah this was me I was ecstatic that
check they cashed right away it was
great his nursery percentage that you
have to have rewritten to get a credit
or yeah WGA yeah yeah it is but if it's
um it's like half and half then you can
share or in my case whatever your
contract can negotiate you say well you
know and I'm fine with sharing credit
with someone and along as it's you know
appropriate absolutely that one guy who
said no credit with anyone I'm still
wondering if he's willing to share
credit yeah sure and going back to the
thing we're talking about like TV
Netflix versus movies and that kind of
that word wine because there is this
blurred line that we have now let's say
yeah but let's say you want to do a DBQ
bird story and lift them where this was
and you're like wow this is like a lot
of stuff and I it's like long and I can
make a feature but it man really
cramming it right um and let's say
you're not quite sure
is it better to write like a miniseries
or is it better just be like you know
I'm just gonna make the best feature I
can and maybe let's say if it goes to
Netflix or whatever but let's say you go
somewhere and they and they're like this
is great can we make it to me seriously
absolutely there's all this stuff I had
to cut out like do you have any opinion
on what's the best way to do something
like that like if you have a story is
maybe like you could make it into a
feature but geez it be better if you
series or you don't know that they would
say making it very serious so I think
you put your best foot forward with what
you think is the best for you okay and
because a miniseries a whole different
structured ballgame than that
and now movies are not just you know I'm
talking about movies for T V is not TV
you know there's Netflix now making 60
million dollar budget movies they're
movies they're just not in the theater
so you've got these really wide
crossings of you know things that we
never used to have before or it doesn't
have to be this select TV or a film you
know but I
at the same time writing a lot of spec
started writing TV pilots as well and
got sort of
you know good with that as well not that
you know so I had two assignment jobs on
that but they were never you know made
into the shows but but it expanded that
opportunity then just pounding your head
against the spec wall you know again
like spec spec so that's why I say look
look at those specs as calling cards and
opportunities to get jobs because if you
don't have that when you go to a meeting
they said what else you have and you
don't want to you know bring beep you
know back up the u-haul and say well
I've got 50 scripts you know that's
gonna be like wow you have 50 scripts
and you haven't sold anything you know
that could look bad too you know what I
mean so you go yeah I have one and then
you you're quiet about the rest of them
until you know I mean like with
literally hey Willis you got nearly hey
you got this project what's considered
like can you just be like oh I have a
good outline do you hit do you have to
have but have something because if they
say I want to see it and you can run
home and the weekend go you know I mean
you're late don't be selling stuff you
don't have I mean it can be what's
expected to be shown on a drop of a hat
is it okay to just have like an outline
where you say I'm working on something
you know you know better to have
something to read yeah I mean I don't
know if they're gonna sit down and read
an outline and go yeah this is great but
we're you're gonna be more impressive if
you've finished a script an outline it's
boring right so you read through and
you're like okay what the hell is this
you know rather I can give this script
to you to write the outline or you or
you
and everybody might have a different you
know where I give it to Shane black you
know oh my gosh you know so if you have
something finished you know where as a
picture an idea is you know it's in the
ether as a million ideas I got an idea
great go write it oh that's my man
versus like it it like it remineralize
something is written down written they
know I don't think they want to read an
outline it's not gonna help them because
they want to read a finished product
they've already done they are clearly in
their head yeah and also the show
outlines not going to show your ability
as a writer or your voice your talent I
mean not to put an outline down but it's
not the same as the the execution of a
screenplay that's the real bread butter
of
wow it's a great TV pilot oh wow this is
really cool you know this is
well-written so you know have that
arsenal before and that's why I say
about the patients so many writers are
impatient because they want to get out
there they want to work but you also
have to be mature enough to pull back
and go not the time grasshopper you know
be very zen mm-hmm
not good and then finally and there's
gonna be people you know might have
something good happen and go ahead you
know but only play that hand when you're
ready when you totally feel who knows
even then right you're gonna it's going
to go through all the different journeys
and levels but but when you're confident
go for it because you can you know
better to make mistakes on your own than
have somebody else's mistakes you know
live or die by your own choices not
somebody else telling you what to do and
go why did I do that
you know this patient becomes oh yeah I
got a handshake
three years ago yeah that's I've had
I've had a president production go we go
in six weeks six weeks I can buy that
car I can because he said it's the
president of production it's not
something wacky you know doesn't cost
anything so we have the three years what
do you do to put pressure on saying
listen he did three years I don't know
yeah yeah I mean I personally but yeah
so what this is going back 20 years ago
yeah office and he had an option my
script for two years again and after two
years it's funny I said we should have
good at the pop where's that great you
think you walked over to the door you
see that name on the door you said Sonny
doesn't say Tommy and he goes I'll tell
you when it's gonna be done
and I said Sonny that's taking the
rights back and it's old-school yeah
taking the right back here like no if
you wanted to put on the gloves like
looks like anyway so now I have it with
another guy three years and you know
we're good friends I know
yeah after three years I keep I'm like
down here when he's working on his own
project that's where do you have a
contract
and and no free work either you know
make producers put skin in the game as I
always say because it doesn't cost an
anybody to say you know interest is
cheap and free I'm really interested in
your script hell yeah oh yeah oh yeah do
a couple of changes maybe change the
ending oh if you're really interested
you will put some money down and we'll
have a nice contract it doesn't know a
piece of paper it says all what we're
all understanding here and it doesn't
have to be a million dollars options
usually 10% of the purchase price or if
it's whatever it is you can make it 5 or
$500 or whatever but it's something that
makes it real because talk is that's the
business is all about that and so as you
know you have experienced it as well it
just takes you know everybody's
interested until suddenly they're not
and then there's string every position
and a little more little got that fish
while they're doing other stuff and
you're like you're burning up my time
here you know that's where the attorney
comes into play and it shouldn't have to
be any battles it should be just
professional it's like professionals act
professionally but not everybody is that
way right so I don't I've heard good
things about it
yeah but anybody else have you know the
blacklist yeah
it's like where other people give
ratings to your script or something is
that how it works I don't know quite no
it's a Hollywood agents it's like
agencies the management right and us all
have an agreement on there's that part
of it where it's they will decide what
the best screenplays of the year are you
know sometimes it's super helpful
because you'll see us you know specs by
right amateurs but you'll also see
Quentin Tarantino's latest script just
because he hasn't found the right
production comes right stuff like that
and then there's another part of it
that's a lot more about community yeah
which is more reason yeah that's more
yeah yeah so again another tool in the
Arsenal you know to try to try to find
that that break you know but like I say
this is all about staying in the game
and that's every aspect of it you know
not just you you is your responsibility
to write but it's also you
responsibility to you know not blame
others because you're not at a certain
place or you cease jealousy or blah blah
I mean I've lost relationships because
I've decided to do this you know
personal relationships and you know it's
like really we I know but you know take
responsibility but on all those aspects
like I said know what's going on the
business read you know these are all
things it's not just sitting down
writing a script you know it's all the
bigger stuff and it's hard to finally
get to a place because we all have stuff
going on our lives you know if writing
is not your main gig you got a lot of
other things pulling tugging at you that
can just lead you you know and then
suddenly it's like three years later not
you're not working hard and I'm saying
even when you are working hard it's like
you know things start to to veer off the
pathway so you have to stay focused and
and when it does happen when you're on
the set it's the most amazing thing you
know when actors are sitting there and
saying your lines you're just like wow
this is so you know I still get a kick
out of it trust me going to set it's
just still an amazing thing how how much
in your opinion does it matter to have
completed like like listen a the options
are times like I can try to write this
like great expect but it's probably
expensive but scummy awesome versus hey
you know I got a buddy
he makes not the best movie but he makes
okay movies and they're made and I can
maybe spend my time to you know
developing something with him that he
will you know they'll have a really good
chance it may even it'll be you know I
get you know two hundred thousand dollar
movie or something let's say in your
opinion is there an extra value that you
get for something that was made if
you're starting out value and having a
credit of course it means you're you've
had a movie made if you want to go that
other way and try to play in the biggest
leagues possible you can spend your time
doing that it's a personal
choice but think about all the stuff
going on the competition of your you
know your spec trying to be in in the
pantheon of I mean yeah it could happen
but 75 specs last year you know do you
want to spend your time on that or you
want to go to something to go wow okay
maybe like I was saying maybe not where
I want to stay forever of course not but
let's say one turns in the next and one
goes by blah and then the third one they
go hey did you ever think about
directing one of these I didn't what you
know never know what opportunity comes
in you know and accredits a credit when
you're uncredited you're uncredited
nobody's taking a chance on you
nothing's been made nothing has been
shown nothing's been whatever so but
that's a personal choice you know I've
had people say oh I you know I've had
friends or actors go it's just it's too
difficult not to be just you know which
is ridiculous like at the highest levels
I said you should be happy to be a
character actor who works you know
entire life like you're that guy or
you're that good yeah you were in the
thing right or whatever but to try to be
the star okay good luck you know I mean
that's a heavy burden to try to doll
depends on what you want to do I'd get
in if you have an in at that company I'd
get in a work the hell out of it if you
have an in that's that's hard enough to
find it in where somebody goes yeah
we're gonna give you a shot and you're
not gonna stay there forever if you look
at some people who are big now it worked
at Troma you know there's all sorts of
things that they worked on they moved up
because it was almost like they were
paid to learn you know I'm saying and
wrapped up the experience which no one
can take away from you and then you have
it over the person who has nothing no
credits nothing it holds out for that
big payday or that big well I want to
have the summer movie of the thing so
did I that's absolutely I did and after
five six seven of those writing this me
okay that one didn't sell yeah you know
round-robin right you know it's not that
you don't give up of course not but you
find your you find your way and it's not
always gonna be the way or the place you
think it is and you have to see an
opportunity when it comes up because
they're hard to get and so if you can
get into a place and start working it
and then some final thing about being a
multi high
I out of film school my film my thesis
film was not great it was fine you know
I had friends who made amazing films
that got him signed you know at least I
didn't go into debt for 30 grand you
know for my film but I always loved the
fact it being a writer because I could
do it anywhere and I could write six
scripts a year I can't direct six movies
here you know and I could be and it's a
solitary thing it's very you know you've
been writers it's great I love it
absolutely love it but after a certain
point you go hmm you know I want to
stretch out a little bit you know and
say I'm tired of having people dictate
stuff and say and you know some bad
ideas and this I want to be more
involved and so you have to say well I
want to be a producer well how do you do
that you have to have piece of material
they say no no I'm not giving this up I
have to be coming with it now how many
chances you get that but at a lower
level absolutely you sell a big spec I
got it pretty with it but on that level
you do three or four of them you can
negotiate a deal and say now this one I
want to produce and the next thing you
know you know what I mean
you start to get in then you start to
have your own project so you think of
because no one can take away your
ability to write or create so it's
important to see you know and it may be
the wrong choice
who knows you know what I mean but
nobody knows nothing but basically like
having something made having your credit
is extremely valuable even if it's a
lower budget smaller absolutely indeed
doesn't matter
people's aw it doesn't matter in fact
the person is probably gonna give you a
job I ain't gonna sit there and watch
that movie they're gonna go oh I see it
worked with blah blah blah you know and
then it becomes about now what do you
have in front of me that's impressive
because you did just like going to film
school no one ever said wow you went to
UCLA film school no one ever said that
in a meeting but if it came up they'd go
oh you got into film school it was one
out of seven chance so that's impressive
because we know you were serious and you
worked your ass off and you went through
it so you know it shows certain certain
things you know
one more question you mentioned whoa
having similar ideas is more often than
not if you approach the studio or
producer and they say well they got
something in development so you get shut
out can you shop that idea your audience
somewhere else or even make your own oh
absolutely because it's yours you know
like the DB cooper thing that's public
domain because you know but we just
happen to find an idea that someone else
thought was a good idea we didn't get to
a first - uncredited knuckleheads my
writing partner and I go well is this
great idea and unfortunately big a-list
actor had always wanted to play this
character and already had the thing set
up and that company when our manager
after our agent cut us loose the funny
thing is after two scripts that he
burned out this is the agent he said
what else you got and so I was like we
don't have anything else and my partner
goes I got it I got a great you know and
we had talked about it but I didn't
realize he was gonna bring it up in the
meeting so he started doing his pitch
and I was sitting there going okay and
then the agents eyes got big egos that's
it right that movie I like that so we go
great we have our marching orders so
we're going to write that movie right
six months later we come back and I
think it was six months I think was six
weeks he took three weeks he took three
weeks to get to it not a good sign from
your agent three weeks and his his his
he called their manager and said it's
not for me
that was his saying see you guys later
you know at three three strikes and out
so our manager said it's okay
which managers do will find a home and
went out herself so like a big send out
because it didn't go out and so she went
out and we got you know some interest in
blah blah and then that's when we found
out about this other company and we're
like oh god this thing's dead dead dead
dead she never know the specter of
similar ideas but I think it means that
you're thinking in a good way because if
you're thinking of ideas that are
selling you're onto something
I know they may be cool apps now oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah
in motion that wind blows it closed oh
it just yeah yeah
so the heck did you have piracy didn't
happen so you can gosh last - yeah okay
how realistic is it for a writer to
genre ha I had a professor tell me that
I didn't know myself and that I didn't
have a voice because I was coming up
with ideas in different genres I said
here's a horror as a dramedy here's a
common comedy and you said you're doing
it the wrong way
genre yeah no I you can come up with
ideas in different genres of course you
can I mean you set to find your genre
that you that you dig you know you like
so you're proficient at it and good if
you don't like horror don't write horror
you know I mean I mean because it's
gonna be like the you know and it may
show through that you don't really you
know if you love horror movies right the
hell out of them I always say find a
genre you love and write the hell out of
it now you can't you may write three or
four scripts your first few maybe
different genres cuz you're still you
know figuring things out it doesn't mean
I have to commit to it of course not but
when you're out there and you know if
you give someone a comedy spec that
opens the door and they make comedies
you're not gonna go back to them with an
action movie unless it's a comedy action
you know what I mean so in that way the
first things that open doors are gonna
be like we want more the same you know
the first thing you sell is probably
going to be that kind of genre you work
in but it depends on the companies I've
worked in different genres I didn't
because the independent way it doesn't
sort of you're working for different
companies and different producers ago we
make this kind of movie you know we make
this kind of movie you know I guess the
last question yeah I'm in a couple of
handshake deals right now and you said
earlier dad it's a good idea to kind of
press pressure them to pay because I
mean one for three years I mean what you
know oh yeah for three years yeah yeah
that's it's been like a few months with
one and like not quite a year
but it's tying you up what's that it's
tying up your you have no way to go so
you can't be peddling to other people so
that's important absolutely if they want
an option and tie it up they have to pay
we have two M agreement it says for six
months
go nuts but then after six months I get
it back or three months it depends but
this stringing a long thing just because
is not good for for you because it ties
up your Tyrael you can't go somewhere
else
my question was more about when when you
have a meeting or your so the reason I
asked is can I do a little bit of
everything I write and produce and
direct and do all the things so the
lines are blurred for me right so I
don't want to step on other people's
toes right I'm the writer or I'm just
the producer right I don't want to be
like oh yeah and blah blah blah so how
how important is it as a screenwriter
for example to also people to talk about
the money side rightly how are you gonna
make your money back
this is a five million dollar script how
are you gonna make at least 20 million
off of it they would probably be like oh
god do you you must be more than a
writer you know do you need do you need
all that sort of information or can you
just go in with the story and not
necessarily be as concerned about yeah
that would I never ask them how they're
gonna make their money back cuz I'm paid
you know I mean it's not it's a whole
different thing
no just here's your ya know those other
thing now that's the only if you get
into producing aspect where you're a
producer writer or something like that
we have more more say in it otherwise
you're just the scribe you're not just
the but you know you're the hired gun or
you're coming and try to pitch your
thing but when you start to get those
other aspects I would keep it just your
writer your writer enable if it is if it
isn't a miniseries it's just an actual
straight up series yeah and they're
expecting you know they're not going to
buy
you only have one season so do they like
well that's where the show Bible comes
into play you're not gonna write a whole
season for free you'll write the pilot
and then you'll do the show Bible and
they go oh and if God willing it sells
then you know it'll it they'll be find a
showrunner and things will change but
yeah you don't come in with like here's
my whole thing and they're like whoa we
didn't even have a chance to have a say
in this you know they want to see
through the show Bible that you were
thinking you know but yeah hopefully an
answer well I thank you all for coming
tonight from far in the air and I wish
you all the best in your projects and
just you know like I said it's uh as you
know as writers it's it's you got to
love it because it'll lead you out fast
if you don't you know so thanks
everybody
five o'clock blue dotnet is my website
it's just got you know everything about
what's going on and my screenplay
consulting services that are also
offering yeah there's a form on there
under the consulting page yet